Angeles County Sheriff department's
sheriff information girl I thank you all
for coming here today I want to get
right into it regarding this incident in
Santa Clarita specifically Saugus high
school now further adue Sheriff Alex
Villanueva and homicide Sheriff's
homicide captain Kent Wagoner w/e G and
E G and yard I Greta inform it's a sad
day in Saugus is a sad day in Los
Angeles County in the nation for another
tragic shooting at a school at 7:30 8:00
this morning Santa Clarita sheriff's
station received a 911 call of a
shooting at Saugus high school within
seconds we received multiple calls and
it within two minutes at 7:40 our first
units arrived on scene and encountered
in the quad area of the school multiple
victims gunshot wounds there were total
of six victims who were promptly triage
and transported to local hospitals for
treatment among those who were
transported turned out to be the suspect
who was currently in the hospital in
grave condition and he's a male Asian 16
years of age and a student of the school
the other five students who have Captain
Waggoner provide they're their
demographics the school was locked down
they did partially evacuation we also
sheltered in place a portion of the
school until we establish who was who
was responsible for this tragic shooting
the surrounding schools in the area were
also placed on lockdown as a precaution
we did identified who the who the
shooter was through firsthand witnesses
video surveillance we confirmed it we
then executed a search warrant at the
residence of the suspect and now we're
going through the very lengthy process
of conducting thorough investigation and
figure out what happened and why at the
same time we're busy now doing the
reunification with the students with
their parents and all the effective
students
I've been notified their families have
been notified and there with them
currently so I'm not going to turn this
over to Captain Waggoner thank you it's
a very tragic day for our communities
and I stand with supervisor Barger in
thanking our first responders the law
enforcement community with Sheriff's
Department our fire department for their
immediate response and preventing
further loss of life in this matter I
also stand with the county the city our
school district allies and saying the
state will bring all necessary resources
to bear as we help the victims of this
senseless tragedy to recover as we help
our community to recover as hopefully we
learn something from this tragedy about
how we move on and hopefully prevent
future tragedies like this but we
appreciate your cooperation and your
sensitivity to what our community is
going through right now we are very
close knit we will come together and we
will survive we just can't afford
another tragic day like this thank you